I would like to express my admiration
and congratulation to the four wonderful
artists that the Academy is celebrating
tonight this is also memoral even if for
me because my friend and mentor Pierrot
Tosi is among them
Pierrot undiluted or better and
interfered with collaboration with some
of the greatest film directors clear
enhance their movies to a higher degree
of visual quality they made them
unforgettable cinematic masterpieces if
you did not know what a maestro was and
you looked at Peters work you then know
the meaning of the word maestro maestro
Tosi Peter wanted you to know how much
he was touched by this Oscar it is made
him aware there's so many people so many
colleagues colleagues you say here an
artist in the industry so many of you
here have appreciate his contribution to
the cinematic art form as a whole it
could not be here but came some of his
most intimate friends and colleagues to
celebrate him tonight
and here among them is another Legend
and Rose my money para tosse is the
greatest costume designer in the world
no question hands down I wrote this and
I'm going to speak fast because I'm told
it's a little on the long side art does
not draw attention to itself or to the
artist it points to a greater truth one
that cannot be expressed in the mind
alone it has to be experienced in the
heart such as the work of Pierrot
Tootsie
tonight we honor this man who has
through his art shown as characters we
would never have seen never have known
in world we we would never have known
but has also helped us to recognize our
connection to stories we didn't know
that we needed to hear
hope you got that sense when people
would speak about someone's work raising
the bar which I believe milena just did
I never understood that expression I
assumed they were talking about a limbo
bar dancing a pastime which is open to
significantly more participants of
lesser skill by raising the bar two days
ago it was pointed out to me that the
expression raising the bar referred to
pole vaulting in which the opposite is
true we got that too and while I think
of maestro Tosi is more of a dancer than
a vaulter let's see it makes no
difference the rest of us will chase
that bar wherever he sets it but to him
I know the bars of no consequence he
answers only to his singular vision
which is of course a great gift to us
thank you